[Music]
good morning everybody thank you very
much for coming along and giving us some
of your morning my name is reza rodney i
am one of the solution architects here
at google currently based out of our
Singapore office and part of the
solution architect role is to try and
find new and interesting use cases to
apply for our technologies and one of
the things I've been able to do is work
with a few banks including Neil and
Ruben I'm gonna introduce now so Neil if
you want to is yourself
hi I'm Neil Boston I'm a head of IB
technology VBS and I also run UK
technology so I run wealth management
and asset management out of the UK as
well
and Reuben I my name is Reuben Lacs I'm
a software engineer on Google Cloud
dataflow and so the project that we've
been doing is making use of data flow
which is our batch and stream processing
system to do grid computing and we've
done some pretty interesting work we're
building out some demos and and some
near realistic scenarios but to just
describe what grid is and some of the
challenges and opportunities but I hand
over to Neil thanks raiser so I'll just
talk through maybe three or four slides
very briefly so and it's very from a
very personal perspective as well so if
you agree or disagree please come on
have a chat afterwards and we can we can
debate some of the points what is grid
computing I guess to me
not to read the read the words out
exactly but basically having a large
cluster with a set of nodes that we're
going to do some kind of analytic
calculation with this generally the way
that I approach it now that can be
deterministic stuff that I've coded in
myself can be elements of ml as well but
basically I look at it as a large
cluster of calculation agents that are
doing some set of tasks generally
hopefully you can make them relatively
stateless and doing a relatively
independent way
so when you aggregate and bring the data
back that could be thought and thought
out in a relatively straightforward
manner so as with most things in my life
I started with three wishes it's not
asking for him for the lis many wishes
is not what other wishes or a large of a
finite amount wishes as one of the
wishes I guess so I when I approached
and talk to Reza and we were discussing
this I guess in London it was actually
in a pub when we first started talking
about it good engineering projects in
London and they were baseball Farringdon
which is very good I started writing
down what my user stories were but they
became three wishes basically so I
wanted to write single-threaded simple
calculation classes functors or packages
I didn't have to worry about things like
multi-threading for example I wanted to
stop thinking about creating my own
directed acyclic graph by temple or not
I just basically wanted to focus on my
IP and my analytics in a very simple way
but I'd like to be able to tweak my
experiments and run my experiments in a
much more seamless way rather than
having to recompile and rebuild a lot of
my analytic classes so what its some
environment I could basically drop my
prompters inside run a set of
experiments get a set of results out and
do that repeatedly either manually or
through a set of machines potentially so
through the three simple wishes I guess
challenges I guess I've been in I've
been markets technology for 150 years
now so a long time so quants I wanted to
really focus about quantitative analysis
even maths
I just wanted my kids to focus on the
maths and the outcomes rather than
thinking about this whole fabric so over
the years that I've been in markets
technology you can spend 20% of your
time thinking about the mathematics and
at 80% of your time thinking about how
you make this thing scalable how you
make it distributed how this thing can
scale and actually one of the challenges
as well as you can spend a lot of your
time I guess my background is C++ it's
trying to optimize your C++ code to run
on your PC which is obviously
you know diminishing returns of scale so
again I wanted to try and get away from
that I wanted people to focus on their
kind of mathematicians and physicists
and engineers to focus on running
experiments rather than thinking about
the other aspects about the ecosystem
and much more about the mass the data
coming back and the outcomes and
analyzing that either manually or again
through machines and i want to be able
to do it very very fast so if I didn't
know which model to choose and I had a
category of models to be able to get to
some reasonable outcome in a relatively
quick way by running experiments a high
velocity was really the the challenge
it's a kind of utopia I guess and what
kind of quality perspective
opportunities running it on demand and
also event-driven they're two sides very
much in markets technology
I want to sometimes revert things at
very large scale and lots of things
which we'll see later in the experiment
but I also have things coming in a high
frequency though I want to deal with as
well so you can think of as a
bifurcation a little bit you don't a
bifurcation in ecosystem or fabric what
about to run a universe of parallel
experiments and then do some assessment
either of them either through some
parameterization through some ml piece
or again manually just looking at these
things in a reasonable way and then run
huge I guess simulations so if you come
from banking and have a look at the way
that the the markets gone especially
with regulation in recent years running
large Monte Carlo simulations for
example on port entire portfolios across
all the markets that the investment bank
of the markets division has is again a
significant challenge and I'll talk
about it a little bit later about the
organizational issues that you have
around some of the technology choices
the banks make to try and accommodate
some of those solutions but again
regardless of the simulation experiment
that I wanted a relatively stable and
consistent ETL style environment that I
wasn't too worried about
now I'll hand over to Reza he can talk
to you date to play sure and so this is
interesting because data flow we use
predominantly in things like ETL
pipeline so we're taking data we're
processing it we are passing that on to
things like bigquery
so why do were you using this for grid
computing to look at this and this was
like after many conversations where
we're sitting down and and storyboarding
this stuff and looking at architectures
you kind of have to deconstruct what a
grid is and then it makes perfect sense
why dataflow is a very good tool for
solving this problem so what is a grid
first of all it's data it's a bunch of
math functions so smart math folks like
these guys you need lots of CPUs and you
need some way of scheduling jobs on
those CPUs so you need to get data and
functions to the CPUs and get them to do
work and you need storage so let's go
through those in a little bit more
detail and we start getting into why
data flow is particularly useful here so
in terms of data there's quite a few
data sources for us there's internal
data sources so the trades etc that
happening within the bank there's a lot
of information there there's external
data there sorts it's potentially from
market environments all of these raw
underlying data that we need to then do
some processing and then there's sort of
derive data so this is data where you've
taken underlying information you've done
some processing on it and you've got
some new data that you need to
distribute for example the yield curves
that are you're creating based off of
things like swaps and deposit
information that you have early on now
the next piece around data is that it
doesn't come in a nice static file
it's streamed it's continuously being
updated again this is starting to get
interesting in terms of what data flows
capable of which is being able to do
stream processing on that data sets are
coming in next it's functions its mass
functions it's a lot of CPUs one of the
interesting challenges fun bits we had
is a lot of the quant code that's been
written in the last 20 years I guess is
C++ and dataflow today does not support
C++ as a
standard language and we had to do some
work and I work with even to get data
flow to run C++ code for us so that was
a little bit of fun especially I was
just gonna say I guess the three point
one wish is I don't want a J and I into
the C++ I wanted to think of it in a
much more I guess an actual way so I
guess that was my three point one which
is rather extreme wishes and I found out
from Rubin that actually C++ is the
original flu right yes so internally at
Google we do run version of data flow on
C++ there was just at the time we came
out with data flow there wasn't as much
of a cloud market interested in C++ most
people were interested in Java or Python
or other languages so we basically made
retrofitted C++ running on dataflow even
though the original flume Java was all
C++ the other piece around this is kind
of that ETL work so you're having to
manage data you have to shape it enrich
it and then once you've got that data is
a place of storing it you need to then
store pull from storage within the
pipeline itself you may potentially need
to do output to storage as well and
these grids have huge fan out so like I
can take a couple of Meg's worth of
market information or even let's say gig
and it generates terabytes of output so
we need some way I'm actually being able
to deal with huge fan out from these
environments and then there's one secret
ingredient that actually means that
weren't the testing we've done so far
has been very very productive and that
secret ingredient is the movement of
data so if you think about the fact that
we've we're pulling source information
we're doing ETL then we're sending that
data to the next stage which is doing
the processing with that data so running
those math functions and then we're
sending that data again to the storage
these are all chunks of data movements
now with dataflow we can actually create
a dag a distributed a directory it's
like a graph sorry of computation and
those connections between all of the
nodes data flow takes care of moving the
elements for me so it starts so this is
again why we start thinking actually
dataflow is a very good fit for this
environment
and when we think about this this this
movement of data one thing I noticed do
I don't actually originally come from a
finance background was you see a lot of
organizational structure coming into how
the dag is created so by that I mean
there's a team that doesn't ETL work and
they generate a file this file is then
moved to the team that does the grid
work and then the grid work outputs
another file which is moved the team
that does the analytics work and what
that is doing is essentially creating
this organizational structure on top of
how the technology should look but
that's not really what you want what you
want is one continuous operation from
beginning to end and Neil will explain
this is a better detail than I could so
I guess this slide here this schematic
is not it's not it's not specific to the
banking industry the way that I've
received it over many industries over
the years is they tend to design
technology by organizational construct
so what you tend to find is people
within grebe a B and C will actually
have a view about how their world looks
and maybe they have specific user
stories that are giving them some some
niche aspect that as the design patterns
well they tend to do is build the
ecosystem above and beyond their own
boundary conditions and then hand over
the data or the information to the next
group so then you end up in data kind of
translation and ecosystem translation
and then reconciliations and that style
of problem so again and it hits Lou you
know like I said it's not just our
industry specifically there's other
industries but I think it can be the
people that start thinking about
technology choices rather rather
actually thinking about what's optimal
for their solution front to back or from
left to right more about thinking about
how their organizational construct is
driving there so again one of the things
I wanted to challenge a little bit was
that we don't need to think about when
we take when we think about it in an
evolution or a revolutionary sense I
guess is to think about how we can offer
something out that actually crosses
those boundaries naturally it has a very
integrated stream based on batch based
approach as well to it the problem
so a little bit more about being now and
a better person than me to describe it
is Reuven one of the technical leads who
built beam and the data flow the writer
for being yeah Thank You Reza and Neil
oh thank you for that clicker
this is this use case is very
interesting to me because as Reza
mentioned I think a lot of people see
data flow as an ETL tool it's a very
common use case to use data flow to get
your data into files or into bigquery
but data flow is actually a programming
model and it's a programming model that
fits this grid use case very well it's a
you you divide your logic into massively
parallel computation with the with it's
stateless functions and then and then at
key points you also say you also put
aggregations where you need to bring the
data together to compute a count or to
write it out to a bigquery and the key
to this is as reza said this data
movement which is one of what are these
things that sounds easy you just have to
move data around and it turns out that
writing a system that can move massive
amounts of data at scale efficiently
with strong semantics never you know
moving it never over moving an element
twice never duplicating an element is
surprisingly hard to do and integrating
that all together is one of the
advantages you get out of data flow that
makes it work really well for systems
like this so the way we have the data
flow data flow designed and presented is
as a three layer system so we have AP
ice currently we have a Java API and a
Python API and we have more API scumming
so there is a go API which is usable
which is usable today in an early access
there's also a sequel a pie so you'll be
able to write dataflow pipelines
entirely in sequel
then there's this programming model I
talked about all these api's just live
on top of this programming model and
then run multiple runners to run your to
run your pipeline so there's the Google
hosted Runner called Google Cloud
dataflow this is this fully managed
runner we just pointed at our cloud and
it runs but yeah we also have open
source runners one one on top of the
system called Apache flank one on top of
a system called Apache spark so your
dataflow pipelines are not they are not
bound to only running on data flow so
this is interesting in the hybrid cloud
case we've also found in the financial
services industry this has been
interesting to some people for
regulatory reasons
if job needs to be rerun on Prem if a
regulator requests it it can be done
with one of these open source runners so
what is the advantage of the cloud
dataflow a system so Cloud dataflow is
one of the runners for this beam API so
cloud dataflow is just presents this
fully managed you know no ops serverless
solution so you don't have to the SDK
gives you a nice simple API to develop
these things but then dataflow manages
security for you and manages the cluster
for you you don't have to spin up a
cluster to run to run your pipelines it
will Auto scale your pipeline so
dataflow will attempt to learn how big
of a cluster you need to run your
pipeline and it will actually shrink and
grow this cluster over time you know as
you get towards the end of your job and
there's less data left data flow will
just start shrinking the cluster and try
to optimize costs as much as possible
there's also a lot of integration with
10 servo blaze machine learning models
so there are tensorflow api is that you
can integrate inside your dataflow job
and there are there's a suite of tensor
flow tensor flow based transforms that
you can run via dataflow so there's a
suite called TFS which is a suite of
machine learning transforms for prepping
and evaluating machine learning models
so a classic example of that is you know
I trained a new machine learning model
and I run a simple analysis on and says
ok it's 5 percent better than my last
model then you deploy it and you find
out that oh it was 5 percent better on
average but it was predict it was
producing worse results for everybody
from the state of Florida for instance
it is actually not a better model so it
turns out evaluating these models is
fairly tricky to make sure that the
model actually is better tf-x provides
Suites of tools to do things that's one
example of the tools that tf-x provide
is good evaluation of models and this
all runs on top of the cloud dataflow so
I mentioned that dataflow lets you for
su run serverless data analytics as
opposed to other clusters where you have
to run a cluster so what is the benefit
of serverless data analytics well if you
look you know this little chart on the
left is traditionally what you would
have to do to run your big data
analytics so there's a tiny little piece
of your work in which you actually you
know worked on your analysis and your
insights your business logic you know
your functions actual quant stuff that
Neil wants his people to spend most of
their time working on and then you would
actually spend about 90% of your time on
everything else
building a monitoring solution to make
sure your job is running performance
tuning you know figure out how many
workers do I need to run this on how
much memory should I give its worker so
what particular type of worker should I
be I run on four core worker serve on a
two for workers or one at sixteen core
workers then making sure my utilization
is up to snuff then you know figuring
out a deployment story and a
configuration story and people with
people would often spend a huge amount
of time
figure coming up with different
deployment stories for the for these
systems research provisioning handle
handle and growing scale so I came up
with something that worked and then
suddenly six months later my input data
is 50% larger the thing I came up with
before no longer works going back you
know resetting going back to the start
and running through this whole process
again reliability setting up alerting
making sure that you know these jobs
actually run reliably and and complete
as I expected the eventers of serverless
is to cut out all of this pie except for
the analysis and insights focus on the
actual business logic you want to run in
your pipeline and let the serverless
system in this case Google Cloud
dataflow handle all the rest for you and
finally we've been saying that dataflow
is not just is not just a product it's
applets a platform and Google cloud
platform is the platform that dataflow
is part of so a platform is actually not
just one technology it's a group of
technologies that often so act as a
substrate to build higher-level systems
so as res res is going to show you here
an interesting thing here for for this
problem is not just dataflow but how can
I use dataflow in conjunction with
bigquery and in conjunction with Google
Cloud Storage and use all these things
together to provide to provide a
solution and distance dataflow has
sources and sinks as we're gonna show
here dataflow has sources and syncs to
all of these other GCP stores and and
data sources dataflow provides a great
substrate to link all of these things
together
so if dataflow so you have sources of
sinks you have an API which in this case
is the data flow API which is your way
of linking everything together saying
read front you know read from
read from this data run these transforms
over it right to bigquery right to
BigTable right to spanner right to
pub/sub right to whatever other sink you
want to and your pipeline is declarative
and you this actually this image here is
actually an example of a data flow graph
in fact I believe the one that resin
will show you in a second running data
and now Reza yep so if I can
particularly thank you so just a couple
of things around the other bits of
technology we use I when I was doing the
experimentation with Neil I don't
actually have access to sort of UBS
bank's data obviously I have to work in
my own environment and we wanted to make
this as real as possible I didn't just
want to make synthetic data especially
for the inputs and the ETL layers so
what we were using was bigquery now
bigquery is google's dead a petabyte
scale data warehouse in the cloud fully
managed and serviced one of the key
aspects that I was making use of here is
that it separates processing from
storage which means sharing of data is
very very easy and this means I could
get access to external data sources in
particular Thomson Reuters were very
kind enough to provide me data so they
have a store in their project where
they're putting historic tech
information and current information
including things like swaps deposits etc
which I need to use to build things like
yield curves they also for pocs they can
put up to 20 years of historical data
onto bigquery and you know I get the
benefit of just instantly being able to
use that stuff without having to move it
around project so again thank you Tom
Suarez for helping me do this if I can
one of the other pieces that we weren't
showing the demo right now but we will
be using and the real thing is today I'm
actually sending even the raw data to
bigquery like very granular data just so
I can show it to you guys but in the
real production system we'd send outputs
the results which is still many billions
of rows of information to bigquery but
the raw data that we want to keep
is going to be many many terabytes that
I would send to big table big table is
linearly scales and we use it internally
within Google for solving exactly that
kind of problem and it's perfect for
this environment because we have many
thousands of cores all running
generating data and if we don't want to
create a bottleneck we can just use
BigTable and linear scale it out and
have all of those calls just push data
directly into BigTable at many many tens
of thousands or hundred actually
hundreds of thousands of QPS so with
that if Neal is going to walk through
the what the pipelines actually doing in
terms of the finance side yeah so I
guess based on the three point one
wishes I set up a kind of very basic
experiment I mean I don't know how much
background you have I guess in an
investment banking and kind of markets
piece but basically the most basic
experiment I could think of was the
source market environments or market
data so that can be things like FX spot
or yield curves or volatilities take a
portfolio a set of trades in this in
this case we just randomly created a
million option trades basically take
that as our underlying data processor as
you can see here
apply some transforms for the market
data which is really you can you can you
can select a set of market data
you then have to apply in this case we
use the we use an open source on library
to produce a yield curve functor i guess
at the end of a an object from the input
process the data I also wanted to create
scenarios so what I mean by that is in
the market you tend to have a set of
points coming in you also want about to
shift things around so you can end up
with a curve with ten points on it for
example and I want to shift each point
independently and I also want to do
these parallel shifts as well so you can
see I wanted to try and create scenarios
on the fly which I thought would be good
just from an experimentation point of
view
then I wanted to run a set of analytics
on it some of which I coded in which is
very basic and then analyze the
experiment so this was kind of the most
basic experiment I could think of I
could choose a different trade set to
make it easier to price and easier to
risk but again it was just personal bias
and preference that I wanted to try
options from up from a personal
perspective so based on the three point
one wishes this is the most basic
experiment that I thought we could start
with just to see what they look like
scenarios again I just chose Mary market
standard things non parallel shifts
weighted shifts independent shifts and
parallel shifts again to create a much
larger set of output data sets more in
line with YC in the market thank you can
we switch over to the top please
so we have a good problem to have with a
demo so we had time this so that it is
actually doing the scenario running
while I switch over to the laptop last
night I was working with one of our
performance engineers from dataflow and
it made it a little bit too fast so what
you won't see right now is this stage
and I'll talk through what that's doing
you would have seen some numbers going
across here but it's already zip past it
oh I walk through what was showing with
now so what I have here is the
monitoring interface for data flow so
the graph that I've built in code I've
submitted a job at the point of submit
the job there's no machines running
everything is cold by submitting the job
data flow starts spinning up the number
of workers that I've enabled it starts
sending my code to the environment and
it starts doing all of the the sync and
source information that we need so in
particular here on the right hand side
we see information about the job itself
it's still running because it's now
pushing the output to bigquery we can
see that it spun up a thousand workers
and in this instance it's using 4000
cores from our environment
dataflow does support auto-scaling so we
can actually let it bring up the number
of machines it needs and then bring them
down I deliberately don't use that
because I just wanted to make this run
as fast as possible which introduces
some potential in efficiencies but for
this demo we're just like start with
4,000 and keep going with the full 4,000
a little bit more information here so we
have able to in my code put custom
counters that actually tells me what's
going on within the environment and this
is tightly integrated to things like
stackdriver
so you can actually have monitoring
going on while you're while you're your
big jobs are running you can see where
things are getting to in this particular
instance we were sending a million
trades and it was the number of scenario
trade combination comes out to 847
million so not quite the billion but we
that's our next set of experiments a
little bit more information these are
some of the options that I am sending in
to the job so but if we look at the dag
itself so I'm doing some reading of
information so there's a market data
that I'm reading from Thomson Reuters
information we have some swap data if I
expand this out what you can do within
the code each one of these boxes January
corresponds to a transform and I can
collapse logical things together within
my code and what that you see there is
like four examples read swap is we swap
what us do is these are all being put
into a single transform the way I've
done this isn't how we do a production
version of this we just have a read
swaps and I just use code to do the
different things you need to do for all
the different data types but I just use
this for good illustration so this is
the read stage if I highlight every
single element here we can actually see
the input and outputs of each one of
these stages now I'm going to move down
and sorry I'm not used the touchpad on
this device one thing that we did as an
experiment that's worked out quite well
is rather than have the trades flow
through
the dag with introspection to the data
sources for all the data that they need
we reverse this so what we have is all
of the trades come as a lump as a side
input I do all the ETL and processing
that I need to do including scenario
generation from the top and then what I
do is because the introspection would
have been lots of long RPC calls and not
long that fast but RPC calls which are
still expensive what I do by bringing
the trades and all the scenarios
together I just do a really dumb massive
fan out with a loop so what it does it
just generates huge amounts of data
tuples so the data that I need to run
which includes all of the values from
the yield curves for example which is an
array of two 9000 in this case doubles I
generate all these values and just let
data flow do what it's good at which is
move lots of data around for me and this
should be that work so here we have the
trades that are being read coming in
from the side and being added in as a
side input so if we was just to explain
a little bit more on what side inputs
are so if you think of kind of like a
broadcast joint if your data is is of a
certain size that will fit in the
environment rather than do a shuffle
join where we're joining all the
elements together you just take this
it's like having a smaller table you
take that smaller table and just make it
available to all the environments and
then when my scenarios are coming in
there goes all that data is there
they're just looping through and any
trades that happen to match the currency
that I'm looking for come out as a fan
out of the scenarios so here we have the
scenario is being generated I actually
do a little bit of optimization in that
we for each piece of work we actually
make it a hundred
scenarios that needs to be processed but
it's a bit more efficient in the next
stage here we have the this is Neil's
code so this is C++ code running in data
flow Neil has written a I'll let him
describe because I have no idea well I
guess basically I took the I don't have
familiar with options pricing there's
nothing particularly smart about it it's
black and Scholes wrote a paper in 1973
on how to price options they
managed to show that it was like the
diffusion equation which is like a
partial differential equation so all I
did is write a thing called finite
difference for a way of discretizing and
solving that but ultimately all I'm
really doing in a c++ is doing matrix
sparse matrix solving calculations over
time so there's nothing particularly
smart if you if you look at the focus
it's probably the least smart piece of
the whole kind of ecosystem I guess well
that's what he thinks I mean days as
well well that's that's where the real
work happens here right this is and this
was a good we use that function as as
something as a good indicator of what a
real thing would look like because it's
doing real work and this is where most
of the work is happening for this
environment so up until now we've been
doing ETL we've been setting up all the
scenarios I've been doing these joins
and distributing this massive fan out of
work which generates as we can see from
the output of this eight hundred and
forty seven thousand results now what we
do next is we go to push this
information into bigquery and if you'll
notice the number of elements multiplies
quite a bit what we do is the code that
Neil has written he's got a spot index
which is actually the thing we really
want but he also has an array of
information which is the it so basically
when I when I do the matrix calculation
which aids array over time to some
answer you get basically a vector back
based against different spot levels yeah
but I actually want the one in the
middle because that's the current spot
level so that's the thing we wanted and
that's the thing which you sent a big
query however we want to record one of
the advantage of being able to use this
data platform is at each stage of the
pipeline I can output results and go
back and look at them because I don't
care about the i/o right it's just
BigTable we'll deal with it
so what we do here is I'm actually used
taking all of those values as well and
dumping them into bigquery now I did
that so you guys can see it in bigquery
in a real production system the spot
index is what we take to bigquery
because that's what you're going to do
analysis on the other values I'd write
to BigTable so if you wanted to go back
and check your results you just go to
BigTable and Victor we can do really
fast index and range scan lookups
so here I'm writing 14 billion pieces of
information rows of information to
bigquery at the end of this so this is
the pipeline running it's now finished
its work I can know it's finished
because we're going to link it looks a
bit almost a bit closer to 15 billion to
me Reza 14.9 okay okay he's the engineer
here right so I'm just going to show the
results as they landed in bigquery so
dissapoint is another point the when
this finished there was no file that I
then now need to load into my analysis
system when this finished it's all done
I can immediately run a query with
bigquery against that data so this is
actually using a different table but
just to show the the principle here we
have grid results the details is 14
billion rows of information which
actually equates to 1.6 terabytes of
data that's been loaded in this table
and what I'm going to do not
particularly smart I'm just gonna say
given the trade number was 8 8 7 6
give me the max spot index across all
the scenarios so when I run this it's
actually going through and doing a query
against all the 14 billion rows of
information and I have my output so
right at the end you can actually start
exploring your data set or generating
the reports that ultimately we're not
doing this all for fun right the bank is
actually running this and want reports
at the end of it we can immediately
start running the reports another thing
that you can explore with and I we we
started to do so this with data lab
which is a notebook that we can do
Python coding against the data sources
because all this all the intermediate
stages of the the calculations are being
stored in bigquery what I did is just
did some exploration with a notebook and
I'm stored it here as a PDF essentially
what we're doing is looking at all of
the information that's available for the
whole pipeline so here this is some
underlying data that I had from
the Thomson Reuters environment datasets
I've graphed some of this information
this is what some of the underlying data
is I actually had a look at sort of the
yield curve creation to make sure that
stuff's looking okay and one of the
things so this is the asset and the new
Murray of the the things that I will
send on to the C++ code both are being
graphed one of the interesting things
here is this is a new Murray and if you
notice most of them are are at the top
there's one weird one and this was an
accident by me one of the scenarios I
typed 0.5 as the amount I wanted things
to shift instead of 0.05 right and by
looking at this I immediately know
something's weird right something's
wrong and this is again something that
the data scientists will then be able to
use throughout the output of the results
now I'm just going to go right to the
bottom and let Neil site explaining this
piece essentially this is like looking
at the the result sets and Neil was
interested in like trying to start
looking at how we can show this in in
three-dimensional space and so Neil so I
guess the thing I was trying to get to
is I'm a big believer in just looking at
a set of results as well to see you know
just things that you can see visually so
when we went down the line of running
the experiment then I asked whether if
there's stuff we could put on top but
you start visualizing what this thing
looks like versus various outputs and
when we looked at this I was interested
to see we were adding up the Peavey's I
guess the present value of a lot of
these trades so I didn't it seemed like
they were relatively canceling out so
actually when we looked at the portfolio
and realized we hadn't randomly created
buys and sells we've done roughly half
buys and half cells so they were tending
to kind of net out in some in some
optional sense we're just kind of
interesting himself when we thought
about the portfolio we've created so
some of the talks actually saw yesterday
in some of the other in some of them
with some other groups there was some I
guess ultimately they really resonated
with me I was trying to get to almost
like having a single inquiry box where I
could type a set of asks of the data
is this thing is this a correlation
against this does this allow this
historical volatility wise how does this
look against like this over time they
seem to me was always this was kind of
evolving a visual representation or
almost like a single kind of inquiry box
and I saw I saw a couple of demos
yesterday where they had that style of
that style of approach and a little bit
of I guess kind of almost saying I'll be
over the top as well so you could take
you could type in quite market specific
language and it would give you back a
set of results around that so I thought
as an inquiry marrying that to this this
style of experimentation out would be
quite strong thing so this was really
just the very basic I tend to plot kind
of like time against spot against Peavy
against other things in a very basic way
just to start looking at what the nature
of the portfolio is but then given the
couple of days I've been here there seem
to be some already some evolutions that
was kind of thinking of around how we
could like start analyzing the data in a
more effective way and asking questions
as well in a much more fluid
experimental sense as well thank you can
we go back to the slides please
go back to the slides please thank you
so just in terms of creating the the
pipeline we in that one we showed you
know the pre-processing stages the
running of the stage is the
post-processing stages and that you know
the semi joke here is like one pipeline
to rule them all right we we don't
create separate processes for each one
of these things we just did one and it
went from the beginning raw data all the
way to the output including analysis and
one of the other so the other thing that
we wanted to do is one of Neil's first
wishes is I want to experiment so as we
now have this dag to be able to do
processing the other thing we want to do
is break apart some of the large years
or more monolithic kuan code and see if
there are linear components in there
that we could distribute again and Neil
and let Neil in room and do some of this
yeah so again it was something that I
guess I should have thought of over my
career a little bit more intensively
about when we got into this sense that
we had stopped worrying so much about
the kind of like ETL piece that we were
running in and the kind of simulation
and ecosystem B's we could then start
really thinking about where there are
parts certainly within the the kind of
code base we were writing that we could
actually look at in a more linear way
from a parallel processing perspective
and again even when we were starting to
look at that the solution that we've
just been talking about that even had
other implications that I hadn't
expected where we started looking at the
way that we could kind of like break
these problems apart from what we've
seen in the past just as just as someone
writing some quantitative folk this is a
common thing we've seen as people move
from
you know there are old systems the new
systems is people have code that was
written assuming I'm running on one
machine and it would be highly optimized
in ways that make it very difficult to
paralyze like oh I'm sometimes you know
I'll spin up threads and then join on
these threads or interleave many
different functions and throughout my
calculation so that sometimes requires
people to rethink how they wrote the
code or maybe out of mathematical sense
look at your functions sake and these
functions could be linearized as a you
know as a combination of multiple other
functions so then we can paralyze all
these things out and get a final result
later and so what that means is that
when you're drawing out the graphs the
more access me as a data engineer has to
the various functions and being able to
split them apart the more I can try and
think of ways of optimizing the flow and
the parallelism within the system so the
more I can I can have like separate
functions that I can pass data to and
from the easier this becomes for me and
this gets another an interesting point
that we found very useful when we were
doing this project together and that's
how we talk to each other so as you
could tell I have no idea half the time
what Neil's talking about when he's
doing the maths it's not my area and
neither is the the finance area however
when we break the problem down for me as
they'd engineer 2 bytes so he can tell
me I need these bytes to move from here
and I need to run this function against
these bytes this output needs to move
here when you start breaking this down
into a way that I understand it becomes
very easy for us to start communicating
and one of the things that we used as a
common language is protobufs so we
started talking in terms of protobufs
I'll then Reuben do what protobufs are a
protocol buffer is it's a it's a common
structure and format for data that has
been used at Google soon
probably around 2001 2002 so it's been
using Google for quite a while it's very
similar in to other forms of structured
data there there are more so some people
use Avro some people use cryo some
people use RIF there are other forms of
structured data Preta buffs are an
optimized one that Google has
traditionally used and is also open
sourced and that made it very easy for
me to start working with neo cuz I could
just give him a definition of how I'm
gonna pass things through or he could
give me the definition and then I know
what I need to do in terms of doing this
process and the other thing it opens up
is this ability now to actually break
apart the functions because if all your
passing as the parameter to the function
is a protobuf and within your code you
start just using protobufs to pass the
information around when you break apart
the big pieces of code it becomes very
easy to plug it into the DAC because all
I'm doing is sending protobufs across
those nodes and that data movement that
we talked about so with that next steps
you know we as we said running C++ on
beam is not standard so we've got an
example that allows you to do some of
that I'll be updating that code a little
bit more after this you know please have
a go and thank you very much for your
time thank you
[Music]